oh my god where do we start what is it
okay we're okay oh I think I [ __ ] this
uh oh well like this a little bit damn
it yeah yeah no regrets I mean it's my
face like what's the worst that could
happen
I'm nervous but excited I'm just really
nervous actually as long as there aren't
any tweezers I think it's all good no I
feel so excited
Nick is a beautiful man he's gonna make
me look like a beautiful lady I hope
we're going from a nine to attend as far
as I'm concerned and may the best woman
were good oh my god where do we start
I don't know wait wait let's what are
these things is this lip gloss I don't
know how much of this to put on the
little brush do you know what this is is
it foundation powder
oh that's Foundation right you already
looks so much better than they do
I forget the disco I'm like gross let me
just oh lord have mercy
oh my god truck share that's what you're
doing to her Oh Lord
I think it's let me take some of that
off okay I'm gonna do one side of your
face I forgot there dude
how does she look is she looking that if
you were trying to come out with me this
makeup like girl go home drunk take her
with you you look so good okay hold on
one thing it's just been like foundation
right like that's all it's happened it
might collect right here cuz I'm crying
it's all the powder makes you feel
alright see this for lips thank you or
for eyes oh let's you lose your lip when
you make a mistake you just rub it in
can you put mascara on your eyebrows
yeah do people do that and we'll do that
right okay
oh wait you can do that
do you like that like any thang anymore
don't make eye contact
weaker picnic mine looks hot look at her
she's like gonna get [ __ ] tonight okay
this is kind of working now right
somebody say yes yes thank you
Wow okay you just [ __ ] it up scarfing
what the [ __ ] is that wait aren't you
supposed to like smash oh honey
Matt how do I look we did it I think I
want oh my god you look amazing
is she hot but it's like my grandma's
make up a little Benny yeah it's a
little casket sharp but whatever um I
kind of wanted to get a little creative
and I was like yeah let's try to blend
the colors up here I'm and then I wanted
to give her make her lips like kind of
push through a little bit more so I'm
like yeah some lip liner much like my
sister used to do in the early 90s all
you guys do is put a nice filter on
there do what the [ __ ] with the eyebrows
series that's my favorite part
um I did a little bit of everything to
Brittany here um we started with the I
wanted to give her a nice smoky purple
eye um and then I've got an idea from
curly to outline her her brows with
something and I think they just really
pop off that you think my lip ends no
yeah these eyebrows definitely pop off
my face well the bride said I didn't get
any in your eye on your teeth that is
true same seam over here so we won Love
Wins look how good she looks the lips
they clearly pop the eyes BAM
but she kind of looks dead
hanger off okay you know what this is
[ __ ] great I look beautiful I mean if
the stereotype that it's like fun to
have gay men give you a makeover like
that's true if it's that they'll do a
good job it's like well maybe not it
yeah it's not true clear clearly false
can't do it but lots of confidence met
penny you look so pretty if I liked
women I would be all over that
why I'd be all up in that